digamos que eres una especie de
ingeniero dedicado a analizar el tráfico
de coches en una ciudad y que quieres
averiguar más o menos cuántos coches
pasan por cierto punto de la ciudad en
cualquier momento y además quieres
encontrar la probabilidad de que pasen
no sé 100 coches o 5 coches en una hora
entonces empiezas por definir una
variable aleatoria x que representa
básicamente lo que te interesa o sea
cuál es el número de coches número de
coches que pasan en una hora
ahora aunque en cierto punto de la
ciudad y el objetivo es encontrar cuál
es la función de distribución o la
función de densidad de esta variable
aleatoria y una vez que la encontremos
será súper sencillo obtener la
probabilidad de que pasen 100 coches por
esa calle o 5 coches o hasta que no pase
ni un solo coche ahora hay 2
suposiciones que tenemos que hacer en
este vídeo porque vamos a estudiar la
distribución quad son y pues hay dos
cosas que tenemos que suponer una es que
la cantidad de coches que pasan por la
calle durante una hora es exactamente la
misma independientemente de la hora que
escojamos aunque bueno osea sabemos que
esto no es cierto en las horas pico por
ejemplo siempre pasan muchísimos más
coches que en cualquier otra hora iba a
las 3 de la mañana también pasan muchos
menos coches que digamos a las 8 de la
mañana cuando todos tienen que entrar a
trabajar entonces bueno para ser más
realistas podríamos mejor suponer que la
cantidad de coches que pasan en un
es la misma todos los días pero sabes
que o sea creo que mejor no nos vamos
por ese camino más bien vamos a suponer
que en cada instante la probabilidad de
que llegue un coche es la misma y la
otra cosa que tenemos que suponer es que
si muchos coches pasan durante una hora
esto no significa que vayan a pasar
menos coches la siguiente hora o sea que
la cantidad de coches que pasa durante
una hora no tienen nada que ver no
influencia en lo más mínimo ni está
correlacionada con la cantidad de coches
que va a pasar en la siguiente hora o
sea que la cantidad de coches que pasan
una hora es independiente de la cantidad
de coches que van a pasar en la
siguiente hora si suponemos estas dos
cosas entonces si podemos tratar de
modelar el tráfico con una función de
distribución que si podemos manejar
fácilmente lo primero que haría yo y lo
recomiendo ampliamente para cualquier
variable aleatoria no solo para esta es
aproximar la media la esperanza de x
y la esperanza de
o sea sentarse en la banqueta que está
enfrente del punto del cual nos interesa
saber cuántos coches pasan en una hora y
ponernos a contar cuántos coches pasan
por esa calle durante muchas horas
aunque sea lo que estamos haciendo es
encontrar valores experimentales de la
variable x y las estamos sumando una vez
que tenemos la cantidad de coches que
pasaron en no sé 800 horas lo que vamos
a hacer es dividir entre la cantidad de
horas que estuvimos allí contando
cuántos coches pasaban y ese va a ser un
muy buen estimador de la esperanza de
esta variable aleatoria
ok así es como se aproximan las
esperanzas de las variables aleatorias
encontramos experimentalmente muchos
valores de la variable y dividimos entre
la cantidad de experimentos ahora en
este caso la cantidad de experimentos es
durante cuántas horas contamos y si
hacemos suficientes experimentos
entonces obtenemos una muy buena
aproximación de la esperanza de la
variable entonces llegamos
hicimos eso de contar coches durante
muchísimas horas y que a la hora de
dividir entre la cantidad de horas que
estuvimos contando nos queda lambda
entonces la esperanza de x va a ser muy
cercana de lambda y bueno esta lambda
podría ser 9.3 coches por hora entonces
te sentaste ahí en la banqueta por
cientos y cientos de horas y el promedio
pasan 9.3 coches por hora y entonces
pues 9.3 es un muy buen estimador de la
esperanza de x entonces veamos qué
podemos hacer conocemos suficientemente
bien en la distribución binomial y ésta
lo que nos dice es que la esperanza de
nuestra variable binomial es igual a el
número de experimentos de los cuales
consiste la variable aleatoria binomial
a ver a ver recuerda los vídeos de la
variable binomial en esos experimentos
de binomial es lo que teníamos era n
experimentos que eran lanzar volados al
aire y ver si caía cara
cruz o águila o sol y contar cuántas
caras salían en los n volados y n
significa el número de volados lanzados
pero para sacar la esperanza tenemos que
multiplicar el número de volados por la
probabilidad de obtener un éxito en cada
volador o sea la probabilidad de sacar
cara en cada volado cierto bueno
entonces tal vez podemos modelar el
tráfico de una forma similar a ver
lambda es el número de coches que pasan
por ahora lambda
coches por
ahora y podemos ver esto como que cada
volado representa un minuto de la hora
en la que estamos contando cuántos
coches pasan y vamos a decir que tenemos
un éxito en ese minuto si pasa por lo
menos un coche en ese minuto entonces
tenemos 60 minutos por cada hora minutos
por hora porque hay 60 minutos en cada
hora que va a ser nuestro número de
experimentos porque vamos a dividir a
esta hora en cada minuto y en cada
minuto vamos a ver si pasaron coches o
no y la probabilidad de éxito que ahora
va a ser la probabilidad de que pase un
coche en cada minuto pues tiene que ser
lambda entre 60 entonces tenemos que
pasar lambda entre 60 coches
minuto haber entonces tenemos esto que
sería como la n la cantidad de
experimentos que hacemos y esto qué es
la probabilidad con la que cada uno de
esos experimentos es un éxito ok en cada
hora tenemos 60 minutos entonces tenemos
60 experimentos y en cada uno de esos
minutos hay una probabilidad de lambda
entre 60 de que pase por lo menos un
coche si decimos que el tráfico se
modela como una variable binomial y
bueno de hecho esa no sería tan mala
aproximación y bueno ya que estamos
viendo al tráfico de esta forma podemos
empezar a hacer cosas más sofisticadas
cómo tratar de calcular la probabilidad
de que en una hora pasen exactamente
cada coches aunque ahí donde acá es
algún entero y está acá pues puede ser 3
y entonces estamos calculando la
probabilidad de que pasen exactamente 3
coches en una hora y pues esto sería
igual como ya vimos hace algunos vídeos
acerca de la variable binomial
esto sería igual a las combinaciones de
n en k
por la probabilidad de éxito o sea la
probabilidad de que pase por lo menos un
coche cada minuto que es lambda entre 60
elevada al número de éxitos que queremos
que es acá y luego por la probabilidad
de no obtener un éxito que es 1 - la
probabilidad de éxito elevado a la enee
- k porque o sea si tenemos que éxitos
tenemos que tener en el menos k fracasos
y entonces como tenemos 60 minutos en
una hora lo que tenemos es que n es
igual a 60 y esto nos queda 60 en cada
las combinaciones de 60 ica por lambda
entre 60 al número de coches que estamos
buscando la probabilidad de que hayan
pasado en una hora o de que pasen en una
hora por la probabilidad de que no pase
ningún coche en un minuto
pero que eso pase en 60 minutos o sea si
tenemos acá éxitos tenemos que tener 60
menos acá para casos hay 60 menos acá
minutos en los que no pasa ni un solo
coche bueno esta no es ninguna mala
aproximación y probablemente
obtendríamos muy buenos resultados
utilizando este modelo pero hay un
problema importante aquí en este modelo
binomial que pasa sin más de un coche
pasa en un minuto en este modelo decimos
que tenemos un éxito si pasa por lo
menos un coche en cada minuto pero
cuenta como un solo éxito aunque pasen
50 coches en ese minuto y entonces pues
tú me puedes decir ah ok sal creo que ya
sé cuál es la solución lo que tenemos
que hacer es volvernos más precisos y en
lugar de dividir cada hora en 60 minutos
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es dividirla
3600 segundos
y entonces estamos buscando la
probabilidad de que haya acá éxitos en
una hora pero en lugar de dividir una
hora en 60 minutos ahora la vamos a
dividir en 3.600 segundos y buscamos que
haya cada éxitos entonces tenemos aquí
las combinaciones de 3600 en k por la
probabilidad de que pase un coche en un
segundo y eso es la esperanza del número
de coches que pasan en una hora entre la
cantidad de segundos que hay en una hora
lo tenemos que elevar el número de
éxitos del cual estamos buscando la
probabilidad por la probabilidad de que
no pase en un solo coche en un segundo
elevado al número de intervalos
fracasados o sea el número de intervalos
que en este caso es el número de
segundos en una hora
- el número de éxitos y listo
este es un muy buen modelo mucho mejor
que este sin embargo sigue sin
considerar muchas cosas por ejemplo que
dos coches pueden pasar en menos de
medio segundo y aquí es cuando tú puedes
decir aunque israel ya estoy entendiendo
el patrón hay que ser cada vez más
precisos y ahora en lugar de dividir a
una hora en 3600 segundos
vamos a dividirla en milisegundos
entonces el chiste es hacer cada vez más
grande
este número de aquí aunque el número de
intervalos en el que dividimos a la hora
y esto está muy interesante ok y
conocemos este número muy muy grande
cada vez más grande y nos vamos al
límite lo que obtenemos es la
distribución razón y eso está muy padre
porque la mayoría de las veces nada más
tener la distribución para son sin
explicar de dónde vino y nada más tienes
que sustituir los números la lambda y
todas esas cosas y utilizar la fórmula
pero aquí estamos viendo que la
distribución pues son
de la distribución binomial y que la
distribución binomial viene básicamente
en el sentido común y de toda esta cosa
tan intuitiva de éxitos y fracasos y
tirar una moneda bueno pero antes de
probar que esta distribución cuando
hacemos que este número tienda infinito
este número que es el número de
intervalos en el que estamos dividiendo
una hora que si hacemos que este número
tiende a infinito
entonces nos queda la distribución para
son tenemos que repasar algunas
herramientas la primera herramienta que
necesitamos es que el límite cuando x
tiende a infinito de 1 más a entre x
elevado a la x es igual a el número y
que seguramente ya estás familiarizado
con él sino búscalo en la sección de
logaritmos o exponentes pero bueno este
límite es igual a el elevado a la a y
bueno para probar esto podemos usar un
pequeño truco ok vamos a decir que x
es igual a n por a y bueno si x es igual
a n por a entonces esto de aquí a entre
x es igual a 1 entre n se ve como una
buena forma de nombrar estas variables
verdad y bueno entonces este límite de
aquí es igual al límite cuando n tiende
a infinito si x tiene infinito como
vamos a suponer que ésta es mayor que 0
entonces n también tiende a infinito
entonces este límite es el límite cuando
m tiende a infinito de uno más entre x
es uno entre n elevado a la equis que es
n ahora y bueno este límite también es
igual al límite cuando m tiende a
infinito de uno más uno entre n elevado
a la n y luego todo este paréntesis
elevado a la a y bueno podemos ver que
la a no tiene nada que ver con esta n
atendiendo infinito entonces podemos
meter el límite dentro del paréntesis y
nos queda igual al límite cuando n
tiende a infinito de uno más uno entre n
elevado a la n y luego todo este límite
elevado a la a ahora en esos vídeos de
logaritmos y exponentes vimos que esta
es otra forma de definir al número y
aunque hay otra forma de representarlo
entonces todo esto de aquí es el número
e y aquí estamos elevando al número e a
la potencia
entonces esto es igual a el ala a que es
justo la herramienta que necesitamos
bueno entonces vamos con la siguiente
herramienta y la otra herramienta que
vamos a necesitar es que si tenemos por
aquí por ejemplo x factorial entre x
menos k factorial lo que nos va a quedar
es
por x1 por x2 y así vamos a multiplicar
prestándole números cada vez más grandes
hasta que lleguemos a x menos que más 1
y bueno
otra cosa es que aquí vamos a tener
exactamente cada términos
multiplicándose
este es el término 1 este es el término
este es el término 3 nos seguimos y este
es el término acá a ver vamos a ver un
ejemplo con números para que quede muy
claro qué es lo que está pasando detrás
de esta fórmula a ver por ejemplo
tenemos 7 factorial entre 7 menos 2
factorial ok esto es igual a 7 por 6 por
5 por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 y aquí tenemos
7 menos dos que es 5 factorial o sea 5
por 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 y entonces lo
que pasa es que todo esto se cancela con
todo esto y nos queda nada más 7 por 6
que es x por x menos 1 y pues x menos 1
es igual a x menos dos más uno que es
justo el último término de esta cadenita
entonces vamos a usar en el próximo
vídeo estas dos herramientas que
acabamos de ver para demostrar que si
tomamos la distribución binomial y
dividimos en intervalos cada vez más
pequeños lo que obtenemos es la
distribución pues son